we had languages
we had words i am who i am
and i'm here and we had
balls you said you want a man with some
balls
let's go this is your the bachelorette
season 16 episode 2 recap grab your
glasses
it's time for roses and rose
balls everybody that's all it's me
lauren zema what
an episode what a ballsy balls to the
wall
episode of the bachelorette bolster
lorette
hi what did you all think of this
episode let me know in the comments
below
episode 2 everybody and we are already
going
deep in so many ways so
i'm gonna pour a big old glass for my
self
and let's get to it clara's here
and i am loving her looks loved this
cool funky necklace with like the
vertical pendant in the middle those
cute green shorts
this first group date is covering the
love languages
you guys know the love languages yeah
and i loved that we all talk about it
right the five
love languages so great first date
really digging in
you know don't drink every time things
got deep a real quick
on this season so far like it's just
touching me
i know i have one of the greatest hearts
in the room seriously
therapy for me
when you start off on night one naming
your husband
i tell i feel like i just met my husband
i mean you have
dove in
i'm looking for a guy who speaks to my
heart so the first love language they're
doing is
words of affirmation and they are having
the men on this group date
profess feelings and thoughts to claire
speaking of words
don't drink for every time claire says
dale i wanted to know more about dale
everything feels so natural with dale
i'm so excited to hear from dale i know
this is a group date but i specifically
picked
dale to be honest group day dale it's
just that crazy
unexplainable chemistry i don't know why
i keep wanting to say dale like that
we had last season sad peter and nothing
about dale's personality or person in
any way
indicates that i should say his name
like this i mean he's tall
good looking charismatic since getting
the first impression rose
i was like on cloud nine i've been on
cloud9 i'm still
on cloud nine and yet i hear his name in
my head as
dale i don't think his name fits him
what do you guys think
i don't know i was almost named rachel i
was nearly a rachel
no should i be a rachel
let me know in the comments below wait
something's happening
oh and then they are running and why i
don't know what does this have to do
with the love languages why are the men
running is one of the love languages uh
physical action
it's not look at that gorgeous of stride
why are you running stop running it's so
hot
and it turns out they're getting a gift
uh because gift giving is a love
language i got my gift
oh a gift to claire was this timed
why were we running he looks like a damn
antelope these guys are sharing
really personal stuff with me and i can
tell
they put a lot of thought into the gifts
so they're all giving gifts and i
thought the gifts that they were giving
were great
but dale man he might really be winning
claire over because we find out that
dale
has dogs having dogs of my own and i
know like how
important they are to you that's some
perfume
for the puppies and claire loves her
dogs she does
she brought them with her she drove them
here with her i think the only lead to
ever bring two dogs
oh gosh what's claire's love language
dogs
don't drink for every love language
physical touch is next
next love language physical touch but
they put masks on everyone blinding them
uh to kind of make it about touch it
became about smells
don't drink for every time someone
mentioned smells
i'm a big smell person you guys claire
smells amazing too
oh i know this smell
now i was surprised that no one got in a
kiss
even dale were you surprised it seemed
like the perfect opportunity but
what i did appreciate and what made me
like dale a little more this episode is
he said he wanted to hold back i'm not
gonna lie
it was hard for me to hold back he wants
the connection to be
about more something deeper the number
one thing i want to do
is show her exactly how i feel without
saying it i tears to that i really loved
it
first of all great job today it's tough
to say which love language is the most
important
and i'm wondering are we doing all of
the love languages because there are
five
no i think we're going to do just
quality time uh because we've run out of
time
right now this is the most important
because it's quality time
so the cocktail party portion is
starting and it's supposed to be about
quality
time spending time with claire time
and claire comes in and she's looking
beautiful
and she gives a toast a toast to time
cheers to finding love
and then speaking of time
there is a long awkward
pause does anybody wanna
don't drink for the whole paws
[Music]
ah so should we get the night started i
think you should
yes claire came in and gave a toast and
said okay guys you know talk to me don't
let everybody jump at once that was sad
but none of the men like jumped at the
opportunity to speak to claire
and she was upset about it do you think
they don't want to hang out with me no
no
very upset awkward silence everybody's
just sitting here
things went from awkward to amped up
real fast i'm so sorry if you guys all
want to hang out with each other
you can do that and i can go home and go
to bed the truth of the matter is it
just hurt me
was she right in these emotions do you
affirm
her words of affirmation i want my man
to show me you care look i get where
claire's coming from in that you
want a man to want to talk to you but it
did seem the guys were maybe just
confused or sort of awkward about the
way the whole cocktail party date moment
was supposed to work
um and a few of them really stepped up
literally stood up
and went right to claire to comfort her
all right can i have some quality time
with you
to apologize and i thought their
apologies were genuine
don't drink for every guy who apologized
i honestly didn't know it was like
time to like take you off does that make
sense but it doesn't matter
like you shouldn't feel like that i'm
sorry for that
that won't happen again what did you
think let me know in the comments below
um i also have to give a shout out to
dale he not only apologized
he affirmed never again will i
restrict how i feel if there's ten nine
whatever men
words of affirmation from
dale oh but then we get a
a different word transition
joseph calls claire
crazy you're crazy to think
that we didn't all come here for you
what's that love language insults of
affirmation
not a good word joseph no no no never
a good idea to call
a woman crazy
and crazy is such a cop-out to me i mean
i was in relationships when i was
younger when
a guy would just call me crazy and if
you are in that situation where
someone's saying that to you
it's just not a productive way of
communicating that means they are not
able to
find the verbiage to convey to you
what their issues are in the
relationship how they think you could be
better
not healthy no no no
[Music]
you're you're crazy to think i would
have in that moment told
yosef two ghosts if you know what i'm
saying uh
what did you think of what he said let
me know in the comments below
okay by the way where was
bennett i think claire left him there
that whole time
sweating thank you for pulling me away
like
it makes me feel like you care so
they've moved forward and claire gets
some well-deserved
quality time with dale and this
conversation
wow don't drink every time they said
felix you scare me because of how
i already feel about you i totally have
feelings for you
yeah like i feel the same way to say
like i have strong feelings for you
we saw last week that claire right away
dubbed dale her possible husband it
doesn't feel like i just met my husband
but this week we've seen that dale seems
to be very much on the same page
of this tale he tells claire that he has
strong feelings for her too
heck yeah hell yeah sure does there's
no denying it absolutely
what did you think of the conversation
let me know in the comments below
dale says he wants claire to know and i
quote there's no more time
quality you need to waste with anybody
else
because i got you like
there's no more time that you need to
waste with anybody else because i got
you
damn dale now what am i searing in my
head
oh i'm thinking of that damn daniel meme
damn dale damn dale
so dale is kind of literally saying that
he wants claire to know she just
shouldn't bother with anybody else
does that happen i'm gonna have to can
wait and see
[Music]
you look gorgeous by the way words of
affirmation i appreciate it oh yeah yeah
but claire is giving some of the other
guys a chance this guy
riley gives her a dance and he gets a
rose i think i'm gonna give it to
right uh and dale even says i thought i
was gonna get the rose
tail i really thought i was gonna get
the rose this is why
i also think the men didn't necessarily
know how the show works dale you already
have a rose
like you're good for this week you
wouldn't get another one
then again no rules you know even with
the roses no rules this season
oh the nerves are back talk to me talk
to me so from the group date
to the quality time of a one-on-one
transition
jason a man i certainly don't know gets
the one-on-one
speaking of not following the rules
you guys you guys you guys
whose voice is reading the date card
if this journey is gonna work i need to
be able to share all of me and that
terrifies me
i hope that you can challenge yourself
to be vulnerable and go deep with me
as well it's players
what did you guys think of this i
absolutely loved it
adored hearing claire's voice reading
this very personal and very
long date card we are going deep
this date with jason is really gonna
give him and i the opportunity to
open up to each other claire and this
guy go on their one-on-one and
man they are really doing some digging
on this date in the desert uh they are
digging into the dirt
they are tossing tiles into the sides of
rocks
and it's therapy this is seriously
therapy for me
you know it's like a spiritual retreat
in the desert and
not that we couldn't all use this i have
to say
that i'm not sure this would
attract me to someone right off the bat
you know what i mean
uh claire barely knows this guy i don't
even know his name well i'm jason
and would you want to go on a first
date with someone where you tunneled
so intensely into your darkest places
we're gonna write down things that
we have been told about ourselves that
hurt us
i mean they started saying these words
about themselves and i'll be honest i
kind of tuned out um
i think it's things other people have
said about them maybe like things we
believed about ourselves
not the nicest comments for sure don't
drink for every
mean adjective manipulative needy
selfish
hard to love can't love too picky
insecure
i'm a [ __ ] cold and mean not
words of affirmation what was a little
frightening to me is that the people
they were describing themselves as
didn't seem to really gel
with each other you know what i mean
like he was saying
i'm manipulative manipulative
and she was like i'm needy needy
and he was like i'm selfish selfish
and i was like this ain't gonna work
i'm afraid that in this pandora box and
if i open it up
there's some demons that are going to
come out that i don't want anybody to
see
but what if you let those demons out it
was just really deep really fast
we don't know this guy yet in the
narrative of the tv show
i don't care about him enough to be
excited to learn all this stuff yet
okay jason gets the rose how could he
not after that you know would have been
harsh
yeah i don't know if you recognize this
holy
oh but whoa wait a minute
wow wow wow we have pulled out
an artifact from bachelor lore
claire has here with her on this
one-on-one date
in the heat of the fire in the darkness
of the desert night
her dress that she wore to
toe off juan pablo
i thought i knew what kind of man you
were okay what you just made me go
through
i would never want my children having a
father like you okay i couldn't believe
it
she still has that dress oh not anymore
she burned it no no one
two three three yeah threw it in the
fire
all right everybody well that was our
first group date and our first
one-on-one
so for group date number two it's
dodgeball
so today we are going to be playing
dodgeball and
don't you dare drink
for every time they said
balls i'm looking for a man with some
balls
i'm ready i'm ready to lay my balls on
the table balls are going everywhere
balls are just flying
past my big bad i really do want a man
who has
i want to see what you guys got claire
you got to be looking for a guy that's
going to have ball control
[Music]
wow hold on hold on
i feel like i want to up the ante here
so the guys on this
group date number two are going to use
their two
legs and play strip dodgeball i think we
should play
strip dodgeball we even have a referee
i don't think he's regulation i think
he's probably
a producer that they put in a referee
costume
blue team take off your shirts and i
will say i
i i don't surmise that this is something
they would have done
on the bachelor with female contestants
so what did you think of the date
let me know in the comments below so
they're playing
and some people are losing um claire
how's the view over there how you doing
and so they're stripping and what is the
blue balls
team wearing look at kenny's ass how is
he so tan
are those thongs leather leg cakes
belong in the bedroom not on the
dodgeball court cotton
why are they so strappy what's our team
aim low that's right is that what they
call a jock strap
i don't know i did theater
i'm processing this what did you guys
think i don't know what to think out the
rulebook folks it's down and dirty now
but i did find some solace and some
comfort
in chris harrison's faces
yes don't drink for every wild look that
chris harrison gave as this game
was going on red team take off your
shirt
[Music]
and then they really lose you said you
want to bail some balls
let's go and so the blue blue
blue balls team has to take off their
jock strap thongs
and we just need to slow motion
chris harrison's reaction
this man's thinking i still haven't won
a skin at me for this
you got to be looking for a guy that's
going to have ball control
good hold on hugs guy so the blue team
loses and uh
claire wants her hugs and you know i
mean i guess we can't blame her y'all be
safe walking home
oh and the naked man they have to walk
home they have to walk home through the
desert naked
and they sit on that couch do we have to
sit next to him
don't drink for every throw pillow
that will never be the same
but the blue balls lost and back to the
red balls team
which won they get some time with claire
as a prize and i still don't know these
guys but whoever this tall guy
is he's kissing claire and he's handsome
that's great who are you
chasing yes every time i see another guy
at this point i already just think
dale i walked home naked
took that as a punishment but blue ball
blake
is not happy no no no he is combing his
beard
and he is wanting more time and remember
he's the one who contacted claire over
the summer
i want you to know that that time you
broke the rule
meant everything to me uh we found that
out they kissed on night one and by the
way
shameless plug i forgot to shameless
plug last week but you guys
i interviewed claire about like all the
rumors did she talk to anyone during the
quarantine before filming started
what happens with her and whoever she
falls for
so fast i asked her all these questions
and that interview is up at etnline.com
hi
hi hi you're a little surprised to see
me yeah
so triple b blue ball blake crashes
the date and i am just loving
his justification as to why he's there
he really explains it he really uses his
words of affirmation for why he wants
this
quality time he says to claire look
i'm pairing how on night one you told me
you liked that i broke the rules
i'm pairing that with
me wanting to show you
that i have balls i'm just kind of going
off when we talked about night one and
like breaking the rules and
doing what you need to do and
i put that with the card today and it's
like
i wanted to come in here and really show
balls and you know what we thought the
competition was over
a bit no no no these guys here that
triple b
blue ball blake has crashed the date
blake showed up
here and they are heading for a
confrontation
i don't want to be but we all we all
played under the same rules bro
i just felt like it was turning into
west side story
or one of my favorite musicals like
good-looking guys
are coming in with their drinks and
they're ready for a
fight we're walking in with our
cocktails
telling blake he's got some nerf that's
not big balls to me bro
we're gonna take a drink so he knows
we've got balls to serve
[Laughter]
they came in with their drinks and don't
drink for every time they
talk about how they won dodgeball fair
and square and i don't think it's fair
to us absolutely
there are some fair rules we want bear
and square they actually
say dude that's not the right way to
show
her your big balls that's not big balls
to me bro
like you're a sore loser
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is happening
like wild i actually
i said that i forgot i actually wrote
down wtf is happening
hey you know what though as funny as
this is can i just take a moment
to speak on something in our culture why
are
balls symbolized with strength okay you
know what's strong
a vagina a vagina pushes out
a fully formed human what do balls do a
little tadpole little microscopic
tadpole
god i never thought we'd go here but
here we are it's the motto of 2020 isn't
it
so our lead newsie who really led the
charge here
is uh apparently named brandon and he
does get this quality time that he went
and fought
against blake for with claire he puts
his foot
in his mouth so fast when i found out
that you were the bachelorette i just
knew
i knew i had to be here so what made you
want to be on here for me
you want to talk about balls to be
honest with you i don't know really
anything about you i know that you're
you know
from sacramento brandon is sweating
don't drink for every drop of sweat you
see
and claire is getting angry and i
thought that it was rightfully so is
there any other thing that made you want
to come on because for me
um i don't have a specific answer for
you claire's basically like
you could've googled me bruh you know
you obviously don't know you on a
personal level and don't know your
history
uh-huh and she says brandon bye
i don't think that i want to pursue this
anymore okay
so is it okay if i walk you out
what did you think of claire's
confrontation with
ballsy brandon now it's a different
party it's the cocktail party
all these guys i mean are they dressed
for a group photo
don't drink for all the blue and black
coordination
no sight of a salmon jacket here throw
it back
and now to a conversation with dale
with dale it's just that crazy
unexplainable chemistry
they feel close to each other claire and
dale i know
how i feel and like beyond attraction
there's a deep connection they feel
natural clay
i'm not afraid to share and talk in
detail like
depth depth i want to know it all uh
what did you babes think of this
i spoke to claire about this shameless
club
[Music]
she is adamant that she did not speak to
in any way anyone other than blake
before the season started
she does say that she looked dale up and
that she just felt they had a lot in
common like his care for his family and
i think that's true i mean they both
lost a parent we know they both love
dogs
they're both in their 30s i see it i see
the connection for sure
the question is just is claire acting on
a connection
too quickly do your connections on paper
checking the boxes of things you have in
common does that translate into a
real life bond but ooh sexual moment yes
i love it uh
claire gets that masked kiss that she
was looking for
earlier with dale these are my dreams
coming true
and then we get the teaser for next week
next week
on the bachelorette oh everybody i just
think this season is only going to get
bigger and better and ballsier from here
the guys are roasting dale what's one
thing y'all don't know about dale
nothing because he doesn't shut the f
but claire says i like him
deal with it if some of these guys are
picking up on
dale and i's relationship and the
connection him and i have
guess what it's because i like him and
and people wonder were they talking
before all this
people alluded to prior to arriving here
maybe they've been in contact with
social media
oh damn and things are escalating
quickly
but that is what this season has been
for me everybody it has
escalated quickly we have gone deep
real fast everything was like great and
then it just went
what did you all think of this episode
let me know in the comments below as
always i am available to you for a
personal message on cameo
i am there on twitter instagram tick
tock
i love you all so so much thank you for
watching roses and rose
no i would never do that to you bye
you